data scientist is one of the hottest
highest paid and most enthusiastic job
roles in the current id industry
business organizations are actively
hiring professionals who could collect
data analyze the market to help the
companies diagnose and overcome economic
barriers to lead the industry
many m c's including the fan companies
are actively upskilling their employees
to bridge the gap in the world of fast
space and intelligent technologies
according to the u.s bureau of labor
statistics now is the best time to start
a career in data science as a number of
jobs requiring data science skills alone
is expected to grow by 27.9
by 2026.
the potential recruiters are actively
looking for data scientists and are
willing to compensate their employees
with handsome salaries
according to the leading websites like
indeed class or nokri and linkedin the
average salary of a data scientist is
anywhere between 10 lakhs rupees to as
high as 80 lakh rupees per annum in
india depending on your experience
in the united states of america the
salary of a data scientist ranges from
hundred thousand dollars to two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars per annum on
an average should you be interested in
becoming a successful data scientist but
don't know how don't you worry as we
have got you covered with our rigorous
survey reports which will help you to
not only choose from the top 10 data
scientist certifications but will also
help you develop and enhance your data
science skills to give your career the
boost it deserves so without much
further ado let's get started with the
top 10 best theta scientist
certifications in 2022. while we are at
it please feel free to get subscribed
and hit the bell icon to keep yourself
updated with the latest it trends in the
industry at number 10 we have cap which
is aka certified analytics professional
will be a great addition to your resume
as a certification is valued by many
data science and analytics driven
organizations
if you're looking forward to becoming a
data scientist this certification is
proof that you possess the critical and
lucrative technical expertise understand
risk management information security
procedures and possess relevant soft
skills required by a data science and
analytics professional aspiring data
scientist with a bachelor's degree and
five years of professional analytical
experience all masters agree with three
years of experience are eligible to face
cap certification exam
there are numerous benefits to the
certification apart from getting
exposure to new and updated technical
skills the certification also paves way
for new opportunities as the
certification proves your credibility
for the role we have the open certified
data scientist aka opencds
on number nine opencds is considered the
broadest and encyclopedic certification
for a data scientist
organizations choose opencds certified
professionals to fill up the most
critical job roles responsible for
producing an effective analysis of data
to improve the business the
certification is available in three
different levels
level 1 certified data scientist level 2
master certified data scientists level 3
distinguished certified data scientists
however there is a prerequisite for
candidates where the applicants are
expected to demonstrate skills and
experience against a set of conformance
requirements through written
applications and peer interviews
next on our list is an interesting one
tableau data scientist and desktop
specialist tableau is one of the leading
business intelligence tools leading in
gartner squadron
tableau offers a wide range of courses
but this certification is absolutely for
free another similar certification is
based on data analytics for interested
candidates pursuing the certification
will help you with data science
fundamentals and also enhance your data
visualization skills
the course covered data prep with
tableau visual analytics data science
with tableau and finally to put your
learning to the test
the course also includes a data
scientist skills assessment
the course requires the candidates to
possess some fundamentals of data
preparation and exploration creating and
sharing insights from data and some
hands-on experience with tableau up
ahead we have ses academy for data
science certification in seventh
position
statistical analytical system is a
sophisticated tool purpose built for
carrying out advanced analytics and
complex statistical operations
getting certified as an sas expert will
help your resume to stand out the course
features hands-on experience with
powerful tools like learn using sas r
python big hive and hadoop
the global recognized taylormade
certification will help you prepare for
all three exams namely data curation
professional advanced analytics
professional ai and machine learning
professional as well
the course will enhance your learning
with practical application based on
actual c studies that will feature data
curation advanced analytics ai and
machine learning your way at your own
pace
we have dell emc proven professional
certification program in the top sixth
grade the dell emc proven professional
certification program is a tried and
tested certification with affirmed
results
dell claims about 73 percent of
individuals found the program to be
effective in their career
23 of candidates obtained a decent hike
with promotion as well about 86 percent
of hr's admitted to selecting the
candidates with this certification with
these ground-breaking numbers this
certification has nothing more to prove
the program is segmented into two
categories the associate level
certification and specialist level
certification the main growth areas
include advanced analytical methods
hadoop and big hive edge base social
network analysis natural language
processing and visualization methods
the development of these skills and the
use of these methods allows the data
scientists to identify and communicate
conclusions and recommendations to solve
business challenges across many domains
if you are interested in wondering about
the prerequisites needed that's good
news for you the program expects only
fundamental programming and analytical
skills and have a good understanding of
cloud computing on the top fifth
position we have tensorflow developer
certification the main goal of this
certification is to help aspiring data
scientists get well versed with
tensorflow and showcase a expertise in
machine learning the tensorflow
developer certification can be
considered as one of the best
foundational certifications for
demonstrating training and deployment of
the machine learning models the
candidates appearing for the
certification are expected to have a
fundamental knowledge of image
recognition object detection test
recognition algorithms with deep neural
networks convolutional neural networks
and exploring strategies to prevent
overfitting including augmentation and
dropouts
the best part of the certification is it
does not have an expiration date
one amongst the top five is simply
learn's postgraduate program in data
science
simply learn collaborates with ibm and
with the best and world-renowned purdue
university for providing postgraduate
certification in data science
simply learns data science certification
is ranked as a number one by economic
times the course focuses on the
comprehensiveness of content and skills
required to tackle real-world business
problems the best part of the
certification program is that it does
not concentrate on one language like the
others
here you get into the master data
science with both python and r
programming languages
the course then navigates you through
advanced machine learning paradigms with
real-time industry professionals and
experienced faculty from purdue
university by the end of the program you
will get hands-on experience with three
capstone projects
and also you will have lifetime access
to 25 plus real-time business problems
and their solutions for future reference
the projects are related to top
organizations like amazon uber walmart
comcast to name a few
the ibm data science professional
certificate stands at the third position
of top data science certifications you
will learn to import and clean data sets
analyze and visualize data and build and
evaluate machine learning models and
pipelines using python you will apply
various data science skills techniques
and tools to complete a project and
publish a real-time report by the end of
the course the course revolves around
python so it happens to be one of the
major prerequisites and along with that
comes sql and jupyter notebook
ibm claims that the course gives people
the foundational blocks to learn and
master data sources we are now at the
top second certification the google
certified professional data engineer you
might be wondering why are we discussing
data engineering it is a fact that to
become a successful data scientist you
need to possess a good grip over the
data that you are working with
data engineer certification will give
you an edge over the other candidates
proving your caliber while handling data
this certification will take you through
various stages where you will learn to
design and build data processing systems
operationalize machine learning models
and deliver the best solution
having a comfortable understanding of
google cloud would be necessary a good
one year of experience with data
management and analytics could add to
taking up the certification on the
number one position we have google data
machine learning engineer most of the
time data scientists are comfortable
working with jupiter notebook
this could be feasible in normal
conditions but if you wish to send your
model production on the website or
mobile devices things can escalate real
quick unexpected issues might pop up
from nowhere and hinder the production
environment
although it is obvious and many
educational programs teach this concept
it is preferred to learn it from the
experts in google's data machine
learning engineer program you will get
hands-on experience in various domains
a few important ones like framing and
developing machine learning problems
automation and orchestrating machine
learning pipelines monitoring optimizing
and maintaining machine learning
solutions
the best part of the certification
program is you do not need to have any
concrete prerequisite to take up this
certification program with that we have
come to the end of this session on the
top 10 data scientist certifications for
2022.
we hope the session was informative and
interesting should you have any queries
please let us know in the comments
section below
until then thank you stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here